est ce que le paysage est pas très beau
mais pas de regarder trop chaude joly se
positionne au lycée felipe dit oui bien
sûr nous sommes un peu dans ma voix
c'est bien canadiennes à halifax en
matière puce doit déjouer
pas de zoom et on est passé traumatique
y arriver j'ai fait jouer je te dire un
cours un jus de retarder porter trop
tard la barre grâce au pot c'est beau
c'est beau c'est beau c'est super super
cheval aux achats ni trois mais je peux
parler je suis en limite si on limite
son charme yens il est envoyé lui il est
amputé aussi ces fonds seront les hôtes
des urnes deux heures un peu trop
gourmand tourner tout de suite faut pas
attendre at avait un super bon plan on a
des parts est beaucoup trop tard la
cassette on se met retourner à limiter
qu'on prépare le plan de la bête en
tournée le point de n'en vaut pas
attendre qu'on soit temps pour tourner
parce que sinon ça y est enfin ben
bernanke eut bon c'est pas passé devant
liu xiaobin parisot on va passer au
dessus qui ont mal équipées hockey et on
est dans des relais quittera au dessus
n'ont pas peur de nous et je tiens tu
vachement bien parce que les vois
vraiment pas jouer un peu sur elle que
sur les on voit
sur le groupe souffre sur le groupe à
l'autre qui regroupe essayer de sortir
de ça
sortir que des heureux
on n'a pas l'impression d'en faire peur
du tout lors nous dire on part ouais ok
très bien ça